voilà moi je veux que moi je veux que je
vais vous dire même vous parler de
malade tant que Pierre Palma dit reste
assigné Michel Marie peut nous dire tant
qu'il reste assigner à l'hôpital c'est
des jours de prison qui fera en moins
c'est vrai ou pas c'est des jours de
prison qui va faire en moi s'il reste
deux mois à l'hôpital ça veut dire que
s'il prend 5 mois 6 mois c'est ce que
j'ai entendu partout dans les infos je
crois que deux mois
j'ai entendu que à l'hôpital c'est comme
s'il était en prison il a raison alors
alors moi pour moi je vous le redis ici
je vous redis aussi tous les gens qui
sont comme Pierre Palmade qui roulent
soukam depuis 30 ans qui roule sous
alcool depuis quand il y a un drame
j'étais malade non t'es pas malade c'est
pas cette malade être malade c'est une
maladie une vraie maladie ça c'est pas
une vraie maladie pour toi c'est pas une
vraie maladie pour moi non quand tu t'en
fous plein de PIF tout le weekend parce
que tu as les moyens de dépenser de
l'argent d'acheter de la cam de faire
des fêtes pas de problème
faites vos fêtes il y a pas de problème
mais quand il arrive un drame ne venez
pas me sortir l'excuse de la maladie
sont conscient dans sa tête pour lui il
considère pas ça comme une maladie
considère pas ça comme une maladie une
maladie pour Raymond c'est quelque chose
qui tombe dessus c'est-à-dire que tu as
demain tu as des destin fait que tu as
une maladie incurable et qui souffre
d'addiction et qui se sont heurté parce
que vous leur dites que non ils sont pas
malade ils sont malades
ils sont responsables ils prennent leur
voiture
mais moi je me dis que voilà peut-être
qu'il faut se faire aider peut-être je
dis tout voilà je dis tout mais si
pendant 20 ans tu peux te déplacer et
prendre de la cam alors peut-être que tu
es mal entouré peut-être qu'autour de
toi ça va pas tu es mal entouré tu as
pas d'amis parce que tous les gens qui
se qui se proclament Hamid pierre Palma
d'aujourd'hui mais qui l'ont laissé
pendant 30 ans dans cette merde jusqu'à
temps qu'on en arrive à ce jour-là là ne
me dites pas que vous êtes ses amis vous
n'êtes pas ses amis moi si demain j'ai
un ami qui qui est malade donc vous
dites je laisse pas là-dedans je vais je
vais le sortir de là-dedans si on peut
rien faire benjaminer
si on peut rien faire je suis d'accord
avec toi tu as des faits comme ça on ne
peut rien faire faut assumer d'accord
je ne pourrai rien faire pour lui parce
que je suis pas son d'accord de la
famille j'ai pas les moyens et ses
proches et j'en connais quelques-uns et
en particulier crois-moi ils ont tout
essayé de tout faire et ils n'ont jamais
réussi
à drame c'est la vie d'accord
les gens n'ont pas payé parce que des
gens font la fête on se droguant on va
en prenant de l'alcool en faisant ça
d'accord les gens n'ont pas payer les
gens qui ont rien qui ont rien fait
n'ont pas payé le fils de ce
restaurateur qui a arrêté au feu rouge
il sort du travail il a rien fait il
sort du travail il se fait percuter par
un mec qui a volé une bagnole drogué
alcoolisé n'a pas à payer on n'a pas à
payer en fait
il y a une époque où du vin et je
prenais le camion après moi je l'ai dit
cette époque là c'est fini on est en 20
avant on roulait moi quand j'ai eu le
permis je roulais à 180 c'est fini
maintenant c'est terminé où on assume de
vivre avec les autres et on se dit qu'on
aussi on dépend des autres et qu'on doit
protéger les autres ou alors on se dit
c'est le bordel on a rien à et on
roule avec un permis d'un autre pays on
roule à 200 et on paye plus rien et on
fout le bordel non on fout pas le bordel
moi moi je vous redis là je vous le
redis là parce que j'étais pas là moi
quand vous avez battu toutes les j'étais
pas là moi quand il y a eu l'affaire
Palmade toute la semaine dernière
j'étais pas là j'ai pas parlé moi je
vous le dis Pierre Palmade n'est pas
malade c'est tout point 30 ans je vivrai
le Banana Café à l'époque dans les
Halles en 1997 je le livret je le voyais
sortir en me disait c'est Pierre Palmade
il sortait déjà à quatre pattes
complètement défoncé le Banana qui a
fixe chez Tony Gomes je lis vrai à
l'époque j'allais à 6h du matin pour
livrer me dites pas que les mecs moi les
maladies pour moi c'est maladie des
enfants c'est le cancer c'est des
maladies fatalisent comme a dit Cyril ça
tombe dessus ça c'est malade faut les
aider ces gens là faut les soigner
maintenant qui passe entre les gouttes
tant d'années qui aide aussi des gens
qui ont dit
mais qui tu passes entre les gouttes
pendant 30 ans ok mais le jour où tu tu
quand tu es au volant il y a pas de
cadeaux alors il y a pas d'hôpital il y
a pas de cadeau c'est terminé